all right let's keep moving and talk
about Angelina Jolie Angie and her kids
were everywhere at the Toronto Film
Festival helping promote her new Netflix
film first they killed my father and now
angelina is pulling no punches about
life after splitting for Brad so you
don't like Angelina well she doesn't
really care
quote I never expect to be the one that
everybody understands her likes and
that's okay because I Know Who I am and
the kids know who I am the 42 year old
single mom of six gives two new
interviews the New York Times and People
magazine topic number one like after
Brad with the kids calling them the best
friends I've ever had Angie seems to
take a subtle swipe at her ex saying
nobody in my life has ever stood by me
more the six are homeschooled learning
Arabic sign language in physics Maddox
has his pilot's license and can now fly
solo and turns out the kids want Angie
to do an action movie Knotts even
offered to help he said mom I can train
you I can help you run do push-ups
as for Shiloh well remember this story
Brad told Oprah in 2008 right now shiz
in this thing first of all she only
wants to be called john-john would you
like some more shoes Angie revealed she
calls the 11 year old simply shy as for
the family's future she says they are no
longer on lockdown she'll return to
acting and they'll travel quote I think
they're itching to get out in the world
again